c'est un chiffre plutôt alarmant la
moitié des enfants de 6 à 10 ans déjà
équipés d'un smartphone selon cette
récente étude 46% des 6-10 ans serait
donc munis d'un téléphone portable sur
lequel ils peuvent passer des heures à
naviguer librement sur Internet et
surtout sur Tik Tok un réseau social qui
cartonne chez les plus jeunes
mettre en garde les parents contre une
utilisation excessive et incontrôlée des
écrans chez les tout-petits qui peut
comporter de nombreux risques je la sens
super énervé quand un regard trop
l'écran en fait et vous laissez-vous vos
enfants sur les écrans
alors
la question
fais une confidence j'avoue que la
tablette comme nounou c'est assez
pratique
pour moi d'abord tout ce qui est réseaux
social chaque réseau social devrait être
sociaux interdit jusqu'à très longtemps
18 ans je vais peut-être un peu fort
il y a un vrai problème c'est que les
enfants aujourd'hui vivent à travers le
réseau social et ça c'est plus possible
donc il faut limiter internet et il faut
que le réseau social ne soit pas
accessible avant un âge si on y va pas
durement et fermement on va avoir des
enfants qui ne vivent que sur leur écran
ça pour moi c'est des enfants en bas âge
14 ans 14 ans
j'ai des enfants donc ils vont ça va de
9 fois 15 ans donc elle petit qui a 10
ans ça dépend ce qu'on fait du téléphone
un téléphone portable à l'origine c'est
fait pour téléphoner absolument mais là
moi je parlais des réseaux sociaux et
les réseaux sociaux oui quand on achète
un téléphone il y a pas les réseaux
sociaux il faut les télécharger oui faut
savoir ce qu'on en fait
sur internet sur le téléphone de ton on
peut bloquer les chargements il faut un
code ça arrive sûrement téléphone
n'hésitez pas à me contacter si vous
voulez des conseils ça se passe très
bien chez moi
je vous aiderai encore le Minitel
l'âge moyen de pour un enfant de voir un
film porno c'est 11 ans
tous les contenus c'est très facile à
faire alors je sais pas s'ils sont
bonsoir
premier film porno en moyenne c'est ça
me fait ça dépend
alors je vais vous dire une chose après
après en raisonnant comme les vieux cons
en une autre époque il y avait des DVD
et encore avant et les BHS et on a tous
peut-être pas 11 ans quel souvenir
Emmanuel quel souvenir oh là là là les
masseuse de Hong Kong
c'est c'est vous Béatrice moi je suis
pas très sévère
non j'ai remarqué quand mes enfants
utilisaient une tablette ils sont
immédiatement irritable énervé et
effectivement ils sont très intelligents
mon fils à 7 ans il sait déjà comment
aller sur Youtube même ma fille de 4 ans
c'est aller sur Youtube et taper et vous
savez vous avez des suggestions de
vidéos et
[Rires]
[Musique]
et petit à petit ils savent naviguer et
aller de vider en vidéo et ça devient
incontrôlable donc les smartphones avant
l'adolescence pour moi c'est absolument
non et tout le monde dedans c'est le
confinement parce que les gens avaient
les enfants à la maison tout le temps et
ne savaient plus quoi en faire et donc
on a tous ces compréhensible
ce qui est incroyable c'est quand on
voit des bébés savoir faire comme ça
mon fils quand il prend un livre il
prend un livre et il prend il fait il
fait comme ça pour agrandir ça joue un
livre ça ça fait peur
ça sur une chaîne sur un livre j'ai dit
ah merde il y a un vrai problème il y a
un vrai problème pardon et c'est vrai
que les réseaux sociaux moi je suis pas
du tout pour les réseaux sociaux pour
les enfants pourquoi parce que ça les
fait grandir trop vite et pendant ce
temps qu'ils sont absorbés et ben ils
vont plus faire de cabanes ils vont plus
aller faire du vélo
moins cher ils vont plus jouer avec lui
et ça moi ça m'embête en revanche pardon
si je peux quand même dire dans mes
souvenirs que quand moi j'étais petite
en vrai je passais ma vie devant la télé
aussi et c'était un peu la même chose
regardez
c'était pareil
sur les réseaux c'est pas bien sûr
parabole d'Europe
d'agression ou de perturbation ou de
tomber sur je ne sais qui et c'est
Dorothée que sur les réseaux sociaux
juste une chose je comprends pourquoi
quand vous allez sur un site de jeu en
ligne vous devez envoyer une quittance
EDF une pièce d'identité on doit vous
envoyer des cotes ça arrive à la poste
pourquoi pour les réseaux sociaux il
faut pas ça il aurait pu de problème
mais il y a des âges normalement mais
personne ne les respecte 18 ans 18 ans
en théorie Tik Tok c'est quoi c'est 12
ans 14 ans on a juste à cocher un petit
truc
là pour le coup c'est il faut voir
directement avec le gouvernement et avec
les autorités ils veulent durcir
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu peux appeler
typiquement
avec les enfants c'est pour ça qu'ils
vont réduire la consommation
quotidienne de Tik Tok pour tous les
parents qui auront cocher l'option pour
leurs enfants et donc déjà l'option de
la attendez une blague arrêtez
c'est une manière aussi de découvrir un
peu nos enfants moi mon fils il a 12 ans
et franchement il est connecté à fond
sur Tik Tok sur snap etc il parle même
pas en WhatsApp il parle sur snap et
parfois je lui confisque son téléphone
quand je le punis et donc je regarde
dans son téléphone ce qui se passe et
c'est un peu le journal intime de nos
enfants c'est-à-dire que grâce au
téléphone on découvre aussi plein de
trucs qu'on fasse dans les mais tu vois
le problème avec ça c'est qu'on ne parle
plus avec nous et la solution
il y a 20 ans il y avait donc le début
d'internet et donc il y avait les
moteurs de recherche et donc je vais sur
mon ordinateur et je demande je regarde
l'historique et je vois vieille femme à
gros seins
donc je vais sur ce qui était tapé et et
mes enfants de l'époque avait 10 ou 11
ans avait fait donc cette recherche
avait donc sorti des photos il avait
pris un petit classeur comptable que
j'avais dans le truc il avait mis toutes
les photos il est pas bête et il avait
c'était fait son petit journal de Mickey
à lui oui et donc les enfants c'était
toi en fait c'était pas mais c'est pour
dire que il y a 20 ans quand il y avait
pas encore les réseaux mais juste le
moteur de recherche et après je vous dis
à une chose je trouve que internet c'est
bien utilisé pour se cultiver pour
apprendre des choses pour avoir des
infos etc c'est quand même très utile
ouais mais non mais
parce qu'on peut lire on peut lire sur
une tablette et de toute façon les
écrans c'est devenu incontournable à
l'école aujourd'hui tu utilises la
tablette pour lire je sais je te reçois
tes devoirs via Internet avec les deux
des professeurs donc les choses évoluent
avec leur temps il faut juste savoir
bien évoluer les choses faut faire un
bon usage et le problème qu'on a aussi
c'est que on est obligé pour plein de
raisons de sécurité d'accessibilité de
fournir un téléphone aux enfants de plus
en plus
pouvoir localiser son enfant
c'est très pratique
ce qui se passe en plus croyez-moi c'est
très pratique